un mot de ce papier du Washington Post
selon lequel administration de Joe Biden
tant très discrètement donc encourager
le le président
ukrainien a négocié avec Vladimir
Poutine le quotidien américain parle de
pour parler secret comment réagit-il à
ces informations
alors l'opinion publique en Ukraine et
vraiment très contre l'idée de
négociation avec Vladimir Poutine
d'autant plus avec les révélations qu'il
y a eu après la libération de la région
de harkis notamment et les révélations
qu'il y a eu sur les extinctions
commises par les occupants russes dans
cette région les tortures les tueries
l'opinion est d'autant plus soudée
autour de l'idée qu'il ne faut pas
laisser des citoyens
ukrainiens dans ces conditions
d'occupation russe et négociation pour
les Ukrainiens riment avec Concession
hier sur Twitter Michael le conseiller
développer a dit en appelant aux gens
qui appellent l'Ukraine la procédé a été
négociations mais vous voudrez qu'on
offre quoi en terme de concession je
pense que
l'opinion très majoritaire en Ukraine en
ce moment c'est l'idée que il est
vraiment pas possible de
faire en sorte que Vladimir Poutine
obtienne quoi que ce soit après ce que
les on fait en Ukraine l'idée de leur
laisser l'activer pourraient savoir
beaucoup beaucoup plus de popularité au
mois de mars qui ne l'a maintenant
maintenant vraiment l'opinion l'Ukraine
c'est que la Russie doit être punie pour
ses actions en Ukraine et tant que
Vladimir Poutine qui a explicitement dit
qu'il ne considère pas que l'Ukraine
devrait exister en tant qu'État et
l'État spécifique de voir les Ukrainiens
accepter l'idée de faire des compromis
avec lui d'autant moins en ce moment où
ils ont le sentiment que leur porte
fermée sont plutôt en bonne position
même si la bataille d'airston est lente
les Russes sont un peu mis à mal du
moins sur la rive nord-ouest du fleuve
avec les destructions des ponts et les
difficultés logistiques logistiques
qu'il rencontre et les pertes très
importantes ce qui disent les forces
russes que ce soit dans le sud que dans
l'est de pays